hello and welcome everyone to yet
another tech enthusiastic video from
simply learn
the ultimate goal of engineering has
always been not just to learn
but in fact to build something
extraordinary that seemed impossible
your personal project is the one thing
that makes your resume stand out
and your skills sharper than the rest
today
we will be going through some of the
project ideas related to java
programming language
so without further ado we shall quickly
begin with our single point agenda for
today's discussion
that is the top 10 java project ideas
so the first project that we will deal
today is the online career management
system
so this particular project motto is to
deal with the career management system
the system will be used for day-to-day
activities like buy
written booking delivery and
non-delivery and
self-pickup etc it is not easy to build
this particular project all alone
as the technicality of the project is a
little complex
for a single programmer i would suggest
you that you
get a team with you and also look out
for some automation in the process
by developing the relevant software
robotic process automation is the new
normal
in today's life the web enabled
interface allows the user to log in from
anywhere in the world
and track their career and also view the
customer rating
the system is designed to integrate with
financial accounting to eliminate
duplication of data entry
and is also scalable to grow along with
your company the system needs to be
built with user-friendly screens
rich in functionality and features and
finally the major part
it should maintain a high level of data
integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular online courier service
as discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product
information regarding the customer
delivery executive
and followed by the delivery executive
we should be also having a payment
window which manages the accounts and
bill reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software requirements
so the software used in this particular
project is the programming language that
is java
database is the microsoft access and
some convenient rpa tools
and finally the ide the id for this can
be any one
which has a good support for java the
most preferable one would be the eclipse
and then comes the intellij netbeans and
many more
now creating this kind of a project will
give you a valuable experience based
on building a fully fledged e-commerce
website or an application
i mean this is how the world's leading
applications like amazon flip cards or
motto etc are basically planned and have
reached
greater heights today this kind of
project on your resume could make a huge
difference
and who knows tomorrow you might even
get into one of those companies and
start working on their projects
or build a company of your own followed
by the online career system
we have the online voting system now
thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own
this is something that we all need today
in this pandemic situation
especially in the current scenario the
internet has brought all the east to our
living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking
ordering food online buying movie
tickets
buying clothes and household items to
consult your doctor for minor
issues bill payments and many more yet
for quite a long time going to polling
booth and standing in a long queue
to cast a vote has been persistent and
it has been challenging
for the government to motivate common
people to participate in the election
system
and cast their vote just because there
is no other way to do such thing
as such an online voting system
but all the credit can be achieved by
software engineers
who can make it possible soon for
everyone to cast their oat
to their respective candidate as their
own choice
with an unmatchable ease
this can be done just by click on their
fingers
this is an advanced java project
developed to show
online voting functionality followed by
the abstract we will get into the
technicality of this particular project
so the first phase of this particular
project has the admin phase
where the admin has the right to manage
the candidates manage the voters
and their profiles and passwords and
finally election results
followed by the admin we have the voter
or the user of this particular
application
the voter or the user gets to register
himself
or herself into the application followed
by that he can use the login and logout
options
and next we have the profile and
password managements
so followed by that we have the option
to choose the positions to vote
and finally to cast the vote now this
particular project is an advanced level
java project
developed to show online voting
functionality it showcases the use of
java servlets html and css again
coming into the ide the ide for this can
be anyone who has good support for java
the most preferable one would be eclipse
and
intellij followed by the online voting
system
we will now continue with the online
healthcare management
named as the corporate medicare
management this e-healthcare management
system
is a web-based project developed in java
the main aim of this particular project
is to provide effective management of
data related to staff and patients in
hospitals or clinics
the features offered by this particular
project should be as follows
it should optimize bed occupation the
project should
improve the use of operation theaters
avoiding the cancellation of
operations to know how much emergencies
affect the administration of the
hospital departments or
services which include cancellation of
operations
to optimize the allocation of human and
material resources to warts and shifts
to detect the influence of certain
diseases in the hospital services
and finally to find clusters of patients
the software requirement for this
particular project are as follows
we need dhtml for the front end and
java as the programming language and
data mining tool
which is waka and oracle for the
database
javascript for the scripting language
and finally
tomcat as our server the e-healthcare
management system is a web-based
application
that assists the management of staff
doctors and patients in an easy
comfortable and effective way here the
concept of data mining
plays a vital role to develop an
effective health care management system
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment
for any healthcare centers to overcome
the drawbacks
in the existing system of healthcare
management
this system is very reliable and
flexible from all aspects
so new features and modules can be
easily integrated into the system
in the future followed by the
e-healthcare management system
we have a new normal online banking
not interesting and arousing for a
normal person but for a hardcore
programmer it is
as exciting as a rollercoaster ride in
an amusement park
because this is how the major national
and multinational banks implement their
banking facilities
in a wide range so that their customers
could experience the ease of banking
at their fingertips one such type of
project on your resume could bring
major highlight to the recruiter
especially if the recruiter is from a
banking or
financial based company online banking
system project is a model internet
banking site
this project should enable the customers
to perform basic bank transactions by
sitting at a corner of their home or
office
through a phone or laptop the customers
can access bank's website for viewing
their account details and perform the
transactions on account
as per the requirement bank employees
can login and add customer
and account information to perform
transactions with internet banking
with internet banking the break and mode
structure of the traditional bank
gets converted into a click and portal
mode thereby
giving the concept of virtual banking a
real shape
thus today's banking is no longer
confined to branches
e-banking facilities banking
transactions by
customers around the clock globally the
features you can offer through this
particular
project are home page for online banking
site
creation of new accounts login and log
out
manage profiles and passwords view the
balance of the account
deposit the amount into the selected
account with ramon from the selected
account
transfer the amount from one account to
another close the account
so the software requirements for this
particular project are java programming
language and
and javascript for scripting language
and oracle for database
and tomcat for server so followed by the
online banking project we have the
online examination project
online exams are normal for us nowadays
but this is totally limited to high-end
exams like cet
gre cat etc the requirement for this
particular project is increasing day by
day because of the current scenarios
many schools and colleges have now
turned towards the online education
system
and are looking forward to hosting
online exams for student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an
online platform for faculty and students
to conduct online examinations and their
evaluations
this particular project has two parts
first is the admin part
admin has the right to add students
create one-time
login adding questions receive answers
and finally to evaluate
followed by the first part we have the
second part which belongs to the
students
so the students can login update their
profile and password
select answers for the mcqs write
answers to questions and finally
closing the session and logout this
particular project can be made a grand
success
by making use of simple java servlets
and java programming languages and
server like
apache tomcat followed by the online
examinations we have the
smart city smart city java project can
be a web-based software developed to
store the details of a particular city
the main purpose of the project is to
help tourists and other visitors to a
city by providing information about
hotels
transportation facilities air ticket
booking shopping details
city news etc the smart city java
project serves the visitors as a guide
of the city and hence the project is
called as
city guide project in java using this
project the details of the city can be
accessed from anywhere at any time
the implementation of the city project
promotes tourism and business
effectively
hotels can be searched more easily from
anywhere
with the help of this online software
students can look out for academic
institutes located in the city
you can view the complete map of the
city using this project
followed by the abstract we have the
features of this particular project
the features offered in this particular
project are login
update profile and password search for
the options select an option
like booking a ticket or hotel or
anything like transportation etc and
finally selecting that particular option
booking that option and payment window
finally the confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools
as mentioned below they are the java
programming language
tomcat server scripting languages like
javascript etc and database
as oracle for interactive data storage
this could be escalated to another level
by following
designed drones that can act like a corp
act as a tourist guide for the people
touring the city
a drone that has capability to take
pictures videos of suspected activities
and store it
for future reference a drone can
intimidate a cop if any suspected
activities are detected
there can be many drones in the city
with different functionalities
and finally you are required to
implement the functionality of the drone
to the users to interact with the drone
users could be
travelers or corps or travel agents or
cab agents
the code for all these projects are
provided in the description box below
followed by the smart city we have the
bug tracking system
the back tracking system is a web-based
application
developed by java programming language
for software companies
the main aim of this project is to
manage the errors or bugs that occur
during the software development phase
and cycle
after the implementation of this project
the employees can update the issue
details
solve the issues and update the system
for any location with internet access
below are the features of this project
and source code of this project is
linked in the description box below
coming into features the software is
applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues
it facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and
solution the system is fully secured and
authentication method is adopted
to manage security it stores the older
bug reports
so that they can easily be solved when
they reappear the application helps the
project manager in
evaluating the works of the employees
and finally
the proposed software is capable of auto
update when the latest version is
available
so the software requirements for this
particular project are
programming language which is java
web-based applications such as
jdbc jndi servlets jsp
and oracle database or access database
as the database
followed by that the server deployment
is red hat jboss es etc and the client
side scripting
as the javascript and the id for this
particular project would be eclipse
with all the my eclipse plugins and
finally the user interface can be
designed using html and css
so with this we can move ahead into the
next project which is
the facial recognition
the face recognition with opencv is an
open source computer
vision library that has tons of modules
like object detection face detection and
augmented reality
the major features that this particular
project offers are
managing the user faces facilitate face
identification
easy login and log out store face id's
identify suspects with just images
enhanced way
to find cyber criminals so followed by
the features now we should look into the
software requirements to build this
particular project
so the programming language we need for
this particular project is
java and followed by the programming
language we need the apache and
framework mingw64 and finally the cmake
framework
so followed by the facial recognition
project we have the next project
which is the vehicle recognition
so java anpr is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence machine
vision and neural networks
so the features offered by this
particular project are
high-level language for numerical
computation interactive environment for
iterative exploration
mathematical functions built-in graphics
functions for integrating matlab and
many more
so this particular project can be
fulfilled by using opencv and
java programming language along with
some natural language processing
algorithms so followed by vehicle
recognition
project we have our last project which
is the
speech recognition system so speech
recognizer converts audio to text
java x dot speech dot recognition
package defines the recognizer interface
to build speech recognition plus a set
of supporting classes and interfaces
so the features or stages in this
particular project are to create a
speech recognizer
allocate resources load and enable
grammar
attach result listener commit changes
and finally
provide the process results so this
particular
library is readily available in java and
you can code this project using the java
programming language and
an id such as eclipse so with this we
have come to an end of this particular
topic that is
the top 10 java project ideas so the
links to the project course
discussed in this particular video are
mentioned in the description box below
you can check them and try the codes in
your own local systems
if you have any doubts or queries
regarding any project discussed here
you can drop them in the comment section
below and we will have your questions
answered from our expert team till then
thank you
until next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here